[Música]
[Aplausos]
la industria de la construcción es una
de las industrias más importantes a
nivel internacional cuando digo más
importantes a nivel internacional ronda
alrededor de los 5 trillones de dólares
también consume aproximadamente el 40%
de toda la energía que se consume en el
planeta estamos hablando de una de las
industrias más importantes y más fuertes
pero lamentablemente son las industrias
más descuidadas también que tenemos y
cuando digo una de las más descuidadas
como ingeniero civil o como arquitectos
tenemos la mala y la mala costumbre de
que algunas cifras que nos hacen
normales cuando digo se nos hacen
normales los incluido también a todos
los que no están dentro de esta rama
donde un proyecto es normal que se
retrase es normal que se pida más
concreto es normal que se desperdicia el
material y estamos hablando de que la
productividad de la construcción va
hacia abajo y si hablamos de todos los
negocios todos los negocios van hacia
arriba a excepción
de la construcción y es triste y les voy
a decir porque una de las grandes
razones por la que la construcción va
hacia abajo es porque estamos usando los
mismos métodos y las mismas herramientas
que se utilizaban no hace sólo cinco
años si ahorita salen y ven cualquier
edificio van a ver que se está
construyendo cómo se construía hace
cinco hace diez hace quince hace veinte
años
cuando realmente ya ha ido cambiando
incluso la dificultad la arquitectura es
mucho más compleja cada vez más
competencia menos presupuesto y seguimos
utilizando los mismos métodos y bueno a
qué se debe esto esto se debe a un
factor muy extraño que sucedió en la
construcción como ingenieros pensamos
llegamos a pensar en un momento de
nuestra vida que la construcción tenía
tecnología y les voy a platicar porque
nosotros vamos a dividir la tecnología
de la construcción en tres etapas la
primera etapa es cuando nosotros tenemos
los dibujos a mano alzada es decir
agarramos un plano empezamos a dibujar
dimensiones el dibujo del proyecto y con
ese se salía y se construía después muy
bravos dijimos bueno ya tenemos la
siguiente etapa la etapa digital donde
entra la tecnología cap la tecnología
acá por sus siglas en inglés es un
dibujo asistido por computadora en esta
tecnología por primera vez es un gran
avance realmente porque se tiene
digitalmente toda la información pero
lamentablemente si nosotros imprimimos
un dibujo hecho en computadora y lo
comparamos con un dibujo hecho a mano
la diferencia es nula y por qué digo
nula porque ambos planos nos están
enseñando líneas nos están enseñando
texto nos están enseñando algunas algún
tipo de información para salir y
construir pero al final el que está
construyendo no le importa si lo hiciste
en la computadora lo hiciste a mano lo
que yo estoy viendo es que de aquí para
acá voy a poner cinco ladrillos entonces
estamos hablando de que en cuestión de
productividad no avanzamos
después entré a la siguiente etapa lo
que muchos dicen es el futuro de la
construcción pero realmente es algo que
ya se está desarrollando y estoy
hablando de lo que es la tecnología bing
pero que es bien bueno la tecnología
bien por sus siglas en inglés es
building information modeling el cual
significa que es un modelado a través de
la información
la palabra clave aquí de pink es la y de
información y cómo funciona funciona por
medio de son elementos tridimensionales
donde nosotros vamos a añadir mucha
información pero aparte tenemos
información de todas las disciplinas que
están participando es decir se tiene la
mala costumbre y voy a hablar por mi
carrera por construcción donde el
ingeniero es el que utiliza el programa
de ingeniería pero el de administración
utilice excel y el de compras utiliza
esta herramienta y este utiliza esta
herramienta eso está mal incluso en
todos los negocios aquí lo que se trata
es agrupar un solo modelo tridimensional
que tiene toda la información
que las personas de compras de
administración de ingeniería tengan
todos los datos y cómo funciona más o
menos imaginas en una computadora que yo
tengo un una columna o un elemento y
este elemento lo que tienes toda la
información técnica así la que le sirve
el ingeniero su área su volumen cetera
pero también es elemento trae cuánto
cuesta o cuánto quien lo hizo cuando lo
hizo si está en la obra no está en la
obra y cada diferente disciplina agarra
la información que requiere y ya
participa costos participa
administración ingeniería y participan
todas las diferentes áreas en un
proyecto
y una de las ventajas aquí con bing es
que aparte de tener toda esta
información esta información digital
nosotros creamos lo que le llamamos un
modelo construibles un bien construido
por ejemplo en esta imagen vemos una
imagen que se ve tridimensional y se ven
los elementos que están modelados en
esta imagen se utilizó teclas reuters
donde se tienen vigas se tienen
tornillos se tiene todo el elemento que
se necesita para poder fabricar pero
aquí es la ventaja de utilizar esta
tecnología bueno esta es la imagen con
la tecnología beam y esto es cómo queda
en la vida real entonces nos estamos
asegurando de que estamos creando en
otras palabras un lego estamos creando
unas piezas donde van a ensamblar
perfectamente en la obra estas piezas
salen directamente hacia robots los
robots empiezan a taladrar empiezan a
cortar las piezas y literalmente es como
si fuera un lego que está en la obra y
estamos ensamblando directamente
entonces esta tecnología una de las
ventajas que tiene es de que dicen ok
perfecto ya tenemos la información que
es lo que sigue buenos ya tenemos el
modelo tridimensional ya tenemos esta
información hay que interactuar con las
otras disciplinas entonces
a pensar en la construcción ustedes
saben los los topógrafos son esos que
muchos dicen ah está tomando fotos son
los que están atrás de un aparato ese
aparato se llama estación total y lo que
hacen se asoman y hay otra persona la
que trae se le llama prisma y va
avanzando y la otra persona toman
lecturas para tomar la medición de
terreno entonces lo que se hace ahora es
que esta tecnología se puede importar
directamente a estas cámaras a las
estaciones totales pero ahora está
increíble que ahora ni siquiera se
necesita una persona que está atrás de
este aparato y cómo funciona antes se
utilizaban digamos en ese ejemplo dos
personas una persona estaba atrás de la
camarita para que sea más fácil de
entender y la otra persona está con el
prisma ahora es un robot que está
directamente ahí y está muy muy
interesante porque tú traes en una
tablet el modelo tridimensional y lo que
haces es de que vas caminando
directamente por tu modelo y dices ok
aquí estoy en la columna aquí
exactamente dónde voy
y ese robot eso que se ve así tan
sencillo sí sí ven ni siquiera tiene un
acceso para que alguien se asome por ahí
te va a volteando a ver yo cuando cuando
lo estaba utilizando hasta le hacía así
y me volteaba a ver entonces si es
increíble porque vas caminando y dices
bueno aquí está la columna te lanza un
láser y te dice aquí justamente coloca
el elemento lo colocas y cuando llegue
al elemento fabricado ensambla
perfectamente entonces decimos que ya
dimos un paso más después dijimos muy
bien ya ya ya estamos aquí ya estamos en
la tecnología que es lo que sigue casi
como el meme donde están todos sentados
en una mesa que propone en línea es uno
que está bien está pues bueno uno dijo
ya existe la realidad virtual porque no
metemos el edificio la realidad virtual
entonces qué es lo que sucede si utilizo
la realidad virtual en un edificio
ustedes se ponen los lentes poner el
celular están viendo el edificio y lo
primero que van a hacer se van a caer
del edificio porque porque no están
viendo a través de los
entonces es cuando nace la realidad
virtual mixta la realidad virtual mixta
es una realidad donde nosotros
ya tenemos el modelo tridimensional pero
aparte yo puedo ver a través de los
lentes y estaba está increíble porque me
acuerdo cuando los estábamos probando me
puse los lentes y yo me sentí ironman o
sea se sentía teníamos el edificio aquí
y yo lo primero que yo bueno y como que
tengo que hacer aquí algún clic o no con
las manos yo así con antes y con las
manos lo agarraba lo giraba agarrar las
piezas y luego veía el hawa vos así se
siente como como ironman y lo increíble
fue cuando me dijeron ahora ponlo a
escala real cuando lo puse escala real
lo que sucedió fue empecé a caminar por
el edificio entonces estamos hablando de
que ya el edificio que yo tenía en mi
computadora el que tenía en la tablet ya
lo traía en los dientes y vas caminando
y estás viendo todo el edificio hicimos
algunas pruebas en el aeropuerto el
aeropuerto traían los elementos que se
le llaman fon y les tienen la altura más
o menos del palacio de bellas artes
arte a partir de ahí empieza a salir la
cubierta estaba lo estábamos viendo y
decíamos ok sí sí va a quedar no va a
quedar se va hundiendo lo van a cancelar
no se van a cancelar pero el chiste es
de que estábamos viendo todo el proyecto
directamente en los lentes entonces
estamos hablando de que ya era la
realidad virtual más la realidad real y
aquí cuál es la ventaja cuando tú te los
pones estás viendo dices sabes que este
tubo bajarlo por qué porque ya está
topando con el elemento que ya está en
la vida real entonces es hacia allá
dónde vamos y por supuesto esto se les
ensambla los cascos y todo este tipo de
tecnología
nosotros cuando hablamos de esta
tecnología muchos lo primero que me
dicen es así es el futuro el futuro de
la construcción y si lo hacen las
empresas grandes quiero decirles que
aquí es una de las cunas bim en todo el
país aquí están las una de las empresas
más fuertes que utilizan tecnología bing
y méxico tiene gran tecnología bing a
nivel internacional es uno de los países
que mejor ha desarrollado esta
tecnología me gusta hablar de muchos
proyectos algunos casos de éxito voy a
hablar de este en particular me gusta
hablar de él por varias razones una de
las razones es porque es un proyecto
totalmente beam pero tras las razones
este proyecto que ven aquí es el
proyecto de hudson hearts está en nueva
york es el proyecto residencial más
importante en toda la historia de los
eeuu de américa
aunque no lo crean fue hecho por mexico
esta ingeniería se hace en méxico se
fabrica en méxico se construye se mandan
las piezas desde guadalajara en tren
hasta nueva york en nueva york que las
bajan a un ferry el ferry se la lleva a
la isla de manhattan la guerra y lo
ensamblan estamos hablando de que un
error en este tipo de proyectos te puede
quebrar la empresa aquí tenemos otro
proyecto que estábamos viendo y es los
estadios de rusia en los estadios de
rusia todos se hicieron con tecnología
bing cuando estábamos viendo algunas de
las conexiones una de las ventajas aquí
en la colaboración de la información los
de rusia nos preguntaban a los de mexico
los de mexico le preguntan a los de
australia y entre todos colaboran para
generar una información a nivel mundial
los estadios de rusia totalmente hechos
con tecnología bing otro de los ejemplos
no sé si ustedes se ubican en cuestión
de arquitectura y un arquitecto muy
famoso que se llama frank gehry este
arquitecto sale incluso en un episodio
de los simpson lo que hace agarra una
hoja de papel hace bola
así como que así quiero el proyecto y
así es lo que hace él siempre en sus
proyectos y se ve se ve la arquitectura
muy compleja se decide utilizar esta
tecnología y es cómo pueden salir estos
proyectos después tenemos incluso el
caso de un hay un escultor un escultor
que lo que hace él le gusta que lo
escáner se para así se sienta incluso
tiene una escultura donde él dice es una
escultura donde están cumplidas parece
que está haciendo otra cosa pero también
utiliza esta tecnología para lo que
viene siendo sus esculturas vemos que
agrega todos los elementos todos los
tornillos y todo para que lo puedan
fabricar hay unas plantas
que se han construido en muy muy poco
tiempo de hecho en el caso de los del
aeropuerto hubo un ejemplo donde dijeron
cuánto vamos a tardar haciendo las
estimaciones se hicieron los cálculos a
150 años no entonces mejor vamos a
utilizar esto y bajó a un año entonces
la tecnología beam es algo que llegó
algo que llegó para quedarse y es algo
que ya estamos implementando en la
normatividad y me despido con esta frase
en una frase pero aunque me gusta mucho
y lo que dice es si tú piensas que has
alcanzado tu potencial piensa nuevamente
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]